i'm going to write the code right now in
the lobby in general so you can see
why don't you just say it out loud what
could go wrong yeah exactly
i i feel like i'm going to accidentally
read it out
yeah don't do it don't do it i just
who someone else needs to okay no no
never mind we gotta start a new one i
can't change the
the i gotta start a new one okay all
right anyway
no code okay data no beta
all right here is the new code the
actual code that we are going to do
wait we have to get out of this one yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah sorry because
he posted made the previous lobby and he
left so
it doesn't automatically transfer
ownership to me it transfers
someone else so here's the new code
i'm so glad that the servers are are
fixed now by the way because
there was a time when there was
definitely a
a time when it was it was the most
difficult part of the game was
you know figuring out always working
always improving
always learning okay okay so who who are
our new folks
let them say hi hi while you guys do
that i'm going to fix the settings so go
ahead okay
we got uh lana i don't know if i was
supposed to do that in that order hi i'm
alana ps i'm a video game writer at uh
santa monica studio um that's so cool i
make content
nice to meet you alana hi hi nice to
meet you alana
and we got adept yeah hello i'm a
content creator
and i also so you also want to hear him
so don't worry
i live with you
the dev loses with http's roommate oh
yeah
adapt and then victoria hi yeah
uh hi i'm the community director at
intersloth uh
who makes among us so if you have any
complaints
so direct them to me but don't don't
actually i'm very nervous
can i say thank you you've made a really
cool game yeah
yeah it was kind of okay to be clear i
like joined like
last week you take all the credit it's
you
oh you're right you're right i
single-handedly invented all video games
yeah great work great work i know it was
tough but
yeah i really believe in myself yeah
thank you for inventing kratos it's
really helped my career out i
really appreciate that
um who runs this the social media is
hilarious like among us was like you're
not me
you really it was like yes is gonna
single-handedly ruin
us canadian oh my gosh
like three three fourths of an inner
sloth like are all american and i'm the
one canadian so i was like wow
it's my time to shine
really funny that was good i thought
that was quite funny did we retweet that
we should have retweeted that i'm asking
someone over here
okay one social person over there please
retweet thank you
okay i think we're good i think i did
all the studying funny though we should
okay we will okay is there anything i
need to know about rules or anything
right now atlanta it's your number one
rule is i basically
for some reason i'm never the imposter i
never get chosen as the imposter so
you can always safely bet on me not
being an imposter i don't know if that's
reliable
it's like it's just it's so much to me
like when i'm like oh my goodness
all these politicians lying to my face
actually honestly aoc i don't know she's
getting away with totally never lying
like i'm the only one who's
ruining my reputation on this game right
now yeah but you're doing
yeah you're doing a great job though you
i think you're representing canada very
well
because you're very magnanimous when you
when you do so yeah okay well that's
kind of me to say um
it was a genuine question though uh are
there any particular rules are we just
doing the mute
unmute situation yes yeah and then yeah
you can see the other the other custom
settings on the side but outside of that
we're just mute mute don't read chat
obviously
you know that's um we we do chat arena
checks
but uh outside of that it's just pretty
basic
sweet all right are we ready to go i
think so
1.25 did i mess up the cremate vision
hold on
let me just let me just reconfirm here
uh
we usually play on what point five or
forty i have i have cremate vision is a
0.5 uh never mind
someone i think someone was wrong they
just
cremate vision is 0.5 and possible is
1.5
and uh i did 2-3-3 that's what that's
what this guy's host was doing
this all looks good i think yeah all
right i'll do two three three
all right let's do it i'm ready
see the other side folks see on the
other side
good luck
i almost moved out of the way and showed
you guys the code
i just wanted to put a jacket on because
it's really cold here in l.a
um yes hi everyone i'm playing with aoc
i actually don't think i know anyone
else in the lobby
um so that's going to make this a tough
one i think
because i don't know any of them
it's just really cold i'm gonna look so
suspicious but it's fine
you know it's it's very chilly right now
all right
okay
um all right well not off to a great
start
but we'll make it work we'll make it
work
this this jumper is so thin why would
you just wait oh yeah to open the door
that's fine we can allow that okay
okay so xqc i feel like we're okay with
um i could go do the one that's in the
middle here oh my gosh it's so cold
it's so cold
i don't know how any of these people
play you know don't have any insight at
all
okay i'm gonna go down here
and i'm gonna try not to die
that is all i would like to do
cool cool cool cool
i'm not no i was about to reach out i'm
not supposed to do that
it's thankful to have it not allowed to
oh is there gonna be a dead body in here
fam did you kill someone
you did not you did not oh someone
already did lights okay well i don't
even need to be here
someone's surely dead i've played this
game
you know oh oh oh oh
um so wow
this was a massacre but this is not
victoria 100
wow okay i did the key task where you
put the key in and you turn it
so i am a not i'm not a i am not an
expert well
yeah you know it's convenient that you'd
say so i didn't even see
the body i just saw a report show up and
i will say the only one who was actually
nearby
was victoria right wow
there you go these people are they are
so good
they are so good
how has this happened it's got to be one
of the new people
because honestly no one of those people
were that good old group
that was capable of this no victoria's
hanging out in places that make no sense
we have to get rid of someone it's got
to be victoria
i think victoria is the one
who was the person who said it
definitely wasn't good
believe it reactor wasn't going off and
she went to reactor i don't know why why
can you tell us why
no okay okay
you honestly might not be but you are
the only one i saw nearby i just feel
like we're gonna
lose this no matter what i don't feel
good about it
this is insane oh my gosh oh my goodness
but there's no confirmation so we just
have to hope we did the right yeah i
think she's using devtools to cheat
yeah yeah yeah yeah totally totally oh
my goodness
who could it be okay all right
everyone's rolling together here
we go okay
this is crazy i oh mike don't kill me
you you
all right ah of course they did that of
course they did that
that was this is ridiculous
wow
sorry i guess the
the dynamic of the lobby changed very
quickly oh
my god those are two gamers
[Laughter]
yo jug me so this is a good example
right now he's stuck in ilo hell with
this lobby
wait hold up hold up hold on uh it felix
he'll cool down's at 20
is that is that two that's fine twenty
two five
yeah okay all right that was that was
really fast but i mean that's not the
reason why you guys
like uh killed all of us but still
holy moly you know usually put on some
like military pants because she's like
we gotta get serious now
i'm gonna do that too let's get some no
i so i decided
that i'm i have a green outfit on
because i'm going to be the forest
ranger
and when we land on the planet when our
mission is done i'm going to repopulate
a scarred planet with seedlings you're
like have to
so adorable so we should all determine
what our mission is going to be on the
planet once we land
as long as we socialize the the
extraction the resources that we extract
because i feel like that's gonna that's
gonna really exacerbate income
inequality if
agreed
look i'm just out here trying to not get
played that hard i'm so sorry victoria
that was yes oh my gosh
legit but it's fine it's fine
i couldn't defend myself it's really
hard to defend yourself i don't know how
politicians do it
yeah because you didn't say anything so
i thought it was legit you i'm like oh
she came in
they give us good hints early on how you
can do that uh one of the tactics they
give us was a filibustering
or stalling uh if you ask a yes or a
question
just say a bunch of a bunch of trash yes
that was a good thing
about the waste time the technique used
by by the
by the folks that don't want to give
answers i can't get over how cute aoc
story
just was like she is a a forest ranger
that's going to
put more life back on whatever the
planet that we do great role play i love
that
space session yeah can we start laughing
is that what this turns into
i think um but the the plants that you
re that you use
to to kind of like reforest the planet
have to be indigenous to the planet
though
otherwise that would just know for sure
yeah that gets out of here yes
absolutely
yeah wait are we are we talking about
ethical terraforming
so we don't want to we don't want to
terraform i don't think i think
civilization i don't know how that goes
down
let's do this this is good it's a real
problem in australia
is there any ethical terraforming
underground this is officer
that then i'm ready what are you gonna
police on a new planet a death
um this this the orange one right here
he's looking suspicious
oh okay yeah this dude's just running
around naked i've seen
that color orange
i'm going to be the first factory owner
on mars then how about that
wow
that's all i'm doing i'm a jobs creator
you can do it if it's a co-op awesome no
yes
sounds a lot like democracy to me i
don't like that
i guess i'll be the chef but i figured
out a way to get drunk off of medical
supplies so
uh don't expect any good food i don't
know what happened to the fried egg
nobody else
i'm going to distribute cherries to the
people
can i need it can i just be the person
who reaches off everyone
i'm just going to remove there's got to
be one oh that's already a song has
someone's already got that role
yeah no i'm gonna yeah exactly
victoria you're gonna be um the musical
entertainment because you have
an elvis hair oh that's true yes man
i'm okay with this i was going for like
jotaro like anime hair but
this works too oh okay what's the
difference really
elvis and anime same thing same vibe you
know yeah
i like this new look jack that's a
better look for you
yeah i like this too it feels like it's
like i don't know like sparta
finally put some clothes you're off my
radar now okay cool thanks
oh who's our lobby i am uh you want me
to start
come on i was just waiting i was waiting
for xqc to go on he said he's a space
cowboy which i
which i dug yeah i'm only for profit me
too all right good
let's get it let's get it going let's
get it
okay the visibility is so low it's nuts
and it's still really cold why did it
get so cold today i don't understand
what is that oh it's an electrical okay
20 second cooldowns i mean jeez fam
these are gonna be short rounds
okay and again i still don't know any of
these people
which i feel like just adds a whole
layer
that my hands so called that i
misclicked
oh gosh oh gosh oh gosh oh gosh okay
hey bud hey you hanging out you
haven't have a good time just getting
some fuel
that's cool me too we could be fuel
buddies
i don't know where you went though again
somebody's surely dead
someone's dead this doesn't play this
way
where are the bodies where are the
bodies
don't buy it i don't buy it i'm nervous
knees week mom spaghetti etc
hey hey guys what did you just do in
there adapt
why did you just go in there and then
walk away
not clear on why that happened
hello okay huh slower much slower
i am on the cameras nice song
what did you see on the camera his body
yes i saw
teal's body on the right uh left door
out of office time to pick it up in the
dark i saw red
coming sort of from there and also uh i
can
probably clear either red or orange i
don't know who it was
i'm clear i did test that sorry where
was it
i did it's exactly thing where you
connect the maze you connect to this
maze thing and connect these things
together
i was there he did it i did it where was
the body
uh so yeah who saw the body yeah left
left door of office
left door of office okay so um
see who did it though i can clear a
depth and natalie because we are all top
right
just now unless it happened who was
saying this
oh felix was anyone on camera before you
were on the cameras
nope nobody hmm
wait who can clear them my cop notes say
otherwise
but okay i've been i've been around
adapting
someone else on the cameras before
that's not saying it i'm comfortable
clearing a depth
but it could have been teal
teal could have filled that muscle who
is not talking about steel
no no zeal is dead deserves
the turquoise oh right i'm purple
i am in that case or red would be the
killer
well then that can't be the case but i
think i think northern
i was with northern northern northern
northern explain your pathing quick i i
went to the right and i did the
maze and then i went to the left
i forget i skipped
i skipped two i skipped okay
thank you thank you okay i said do you
think it's northern peru you know just
don't kill anyone
he's stuttering and i'm ready i got my
clear
eight seconds to make my case
wow i can't see that's gonna be
good for them these whoever is doing
this is
locking all these doors they know what
they they up to is all i'm saying
okay i do think adept is good
i need to get more fuel i hate being in
this room because it seems like such a
good place to die there's a vent point
right there like
am i trying to get murdered no
why did this keep happening to me
and then i think this task is done
i just don't feel like any of this is
going to go well for us right now
so it wasn't northern um
i was clearing asteroids hassan was very
quick on voting for northern it's all
i'm saying
i'm i'm i'm near storage
what was that me hassan
and then i saw two dots two dots and
weapons
and then one dot left so i want to go
see the other dot
the dot is dead so whoever wants weapons
at all
ever is your killer and elana literally
said she was at weapons
i've not been to weapons and i never
said that even once uh
all i said this time was that we should
vote hassan because he was so sure that
it was northern and northern is now dead
uh i never went to weapons i i was never
at weapons why did you say alana was at
weapons
i wasn't waiting for him
no let's get this right
i haven't done anything what i'm pretty
confident about
for a while and northern was like doing
stuff and i was doing stuff we're proper
but then northern got killed so i i
paused by
they clear anyone this time around i i
did fuel and then went to the top left
to fuel and then i headed towards med
bay
um which i think is lava well you said
you say you were doing fuel yeah i went
into the little fuel thing
uh xqc walked past me while i headed in
there and i was like oh no this would be
a great place to get murdered did you
know that i walked out
thanks did you pass each other maybe
i don't know
i feel like that's the i feel like that
was the right call that was it was not
the right call
but i don't know who the killer is if
we're being honest though i don't know
it's not me it went wrong we're in a lot
of trouble
i feel like i was thrown under the bus
too hard
here and i have to remember who did it
and the problem is i don't know these
people's voices so i can't even tell you
who said what damn it
she's got a chill card swipe you just
gotta slow it down
um who was the person who said that i
said that i went to weapons because i
never said that
is the thing you know i did not ever say
that
that person i think be lying
this map it just feels so big now too
are you gonna kill me
you're gonna kill me aren't you am i
gonna get murdered here
because i sort of feel like i am
i do have to go down here i think you
could have already killed me if you
wanted
is my problem what are you
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten
done okay then maybe that clears you
do it natalie no nothing okay
all right so i was right about the song
that was just contra oh my goodness yeah
you carried
so
i did not want to do it but it was too
it was too spicy of an
area not to it was a perfect place to
murder someone yeah i literally wasn't
gonna do it but i was like i have to do
it
sometimes it'd be like victoria where
did you die
uh i died near the bottom i was like i
was like i was so sure i was like oh
natalie can vouch for me if i just stick
close to natalie and then she killed me
so mad i was hoping you would think that
i'm so betrayed we'll team up we'll
we'll watch each other
i was lulled in by your siren song i was
like yes
i was standing in the doorway at the end
there with you natalie and i was like
just kill me just do it do it natalie
murder
that's a good thing i'm a youtuber not a
politician because i don't deserve
responsibility
you know you did great you did great
that was very impressive yeah no
it was just an evil responsibility
oh my goodness being a youtuber is
hassan do you have uh somebody else on
deck because i think this will have to
be my last one
i i do have another person uh who can
come in yeah
okay i'll make this my last one and then
free up some room
yeah we'll we'll hold on let me just let
me just text him make sure
we can always pull in another dev if we
need to
wait is there anyone else that wants to
leave as well i mean we don't re like
i can bring in some other people if
necessary but right now we just have one
extra fill
so no i think i think i'll probably be
popping out in a game or two
okay yeah i'll do another you know i'll
do another one that's what that's where
my mindset was at
i'm glad
cool i didn't mean to kill the whole
lobby yeah you killed the fighter
i didn't mean any defense you know
you know between nine other people as
lovely as you
are versus my newborn daughter i gotta
weigh
the congratulations priorities
i was fishing for it no no not a real
gamer
not a reader not a real gamer has has a
child and responsibilities it's fine
hey some people out here saying that
being a parent is the dark souls of life
so true think about that that's a great
expression
i didn't get that at all
it's just really hard okay it's just
real hot it's a very very hard video
game it's very late
you know unpopular game you probably
haven't heard of it from an indie studio
i get it
it's a game that i finished by the way
and people lie and say i didn't but i
actually
well it sounds like what is the game
depending on your definition the basis
of it it's a lot of pain and suffering
and not much of a payout
what is it about rewarding it's like the
only game it's the only single player
game that i feel
the same amount of like reward that you
get from a multiplayer game i think
yeah i agree with that like when you
finally kill like the nameless king
like after hours hey are you leaving are
you leaving is that
no it wasn't i just wanted to talk about
my favorite bus
i'm just kidding you should ask corpse
if he wants to join
i can't i can't reach him i have no way
of reaching him
like i would love to have a mom but i i
i'll
i'll pay jim i'll pay them i'm sure
there's ways to reach my chat has been
my chat has been asking for him as well
and it would be great to have him on i
just have no way of reaching him
okay i'm gonna respond to him on twitter
he
he tweeted at me apparently two hours
ago i didn't see it but i'll
oh he is he's a very dedicated fan base
i'm sure they they will let you know
if he's tweeted at you yeah i think i've
been seeing people talking chat about it
uh
yeah no they've they've been in my chat
non-stop uh blasting like why don't you
bring him in it's like
well i can't i don't know what to do
like sorry like what do you want me to
do
like blow a horn to get him in here if
he wants to hop on
yeah i will gladly turn myself at him
is everybody trying to leave now what's
going on okay let's just are we starting
are you guys ready let's do it let's do
it let's just do this i am ready
okay this is stressful man my uh my
apple watch is
doing something that aoc's the watch was
doing oh no is it doing the thing oh
really
the heartbeat
okay
cool
where did you stay cremate that would be
nice
that would be real nice for me i would
have a really great time
i should probably go fix those lights
because this is such a good way to get
murdered i can't believe how low
visibility
is i was right
it's almost like i knew what i was
talking about oh my god
yes see
impressive that was fast oh
two people two okay and i were going to
go fix the lights
so i i can't wait for aot i was i was
already in the light fixing room and i
just saw aoc come in when the thing got
uh announced
yes so i can vouch for you he's legit i
was right behind her
from where uh from
that's a good question i don't know the
map that well to describe from where
from
maybe even another dead body where is it
wait sorry no
someone else walked in behind him okay
it's in that bed but what happened there
is that
alana was moving very irresponsibly and
knew she was going to die i went with
her
that is that is true yeah and then i i
hit
this right somewhere and she died i let
her die
you know what you know what deputy xqc
that's a good read i'm gonna have to add
you to the force
i would like the record just i'm dead
but i would like the record to show that
i said i'm totally gonna die here right
before i got killed
how does that move irresponsibly
and they're going very dangerous
isolated places he's correct
she's moving your response okay so where
is everyone else i know where xtc
aoc wait i was in this country
in the power room there were two in the
cover i was i was already standing in
the power room i saw i saw aoc walking
oh i got invited by aoc
that's us three so they invited me
themselves like i said i don't know
anyone else
have no idea so no service is legit so
let's say oh there's no time
lights we're going live we're going down
we're going to skip and you came from
top but you need to go to lights
whenever it's cool
already standing in that room i saw i
saw aoc walk into that room oh okay and
then your mouth is disconnected so you
can
get to know people uh that's the that's
the beauty of among us is really putting
people together you know making friends
being social um and getting murdered by
complete strangers because the lights
were out i didn't take a risk
[Laughter]
but i was right there i was right there
and i was like you know what someone
else is gonna fix the lights in no time
we'll be just fine
and then i don't got murdered we never
finish tasks these people no it's not
gonna work i don't know who the other
killer is
i don't know if these people know how to
use chat though that's the problem
who is other murderer i'm just not gonna
do my tasks oh
wow hey hassan that's your dead body
right there really just right there
hanging out being dead unfound cold
alone in the snow
okay so it's adept then
so so it's adept is what you're telling
me because that's
the risks you take the risks
now you're just in a circle with two
dead bodies
what are you surely you're gonna get
caught
oh my gosh
you're just hanging out next to them
what's the play oh my god everyone's
dead
surely they only have to kill like one
mole this is some of the strangest
did you not see that buddy
oh my god i was i was uh watching you
guys was wild
whoa damn those plays
wow good work good work what did they do
it's just killed everyone so ruthlessly
too like standing near dead bodies
damn i didn't i didn't suspect either of
you i thought i thought it was xqc
right yeah me too when sometimes you
just get awed by the just the skill
level out there
yeah wow uh it's the nicest thing
anyone's ever said about my
gaming skill first you're like shocks
okay
that was a quick game so surely you have
time for one more one more okay one more
i'm gonna do one more
should i change before we do it oh okay
okay
like feel like you think i should change
the pass a little bit because like
all the games have been real quick sure
that sketch you can remove uh like a
short dash or two
remove one long one short yo
you all do the tasks like we're not
doing a task
so i'm not doing the task because we're
finishing everything too
like we have not gotten even close to
having a round where we've needed to
finish all the tasks so when i'm a ghost
i'm just not even trying
um so maybe have less tasks would i
think
yeah one long short yeah maybe no no
it's i mean it's cool we were
the other way around was for a long time
it was uh the christmas
feel like we have an issue with having
oh okay yeah that's fair i was gonna say
we
i haven't we just had three impostor
wins in a row so yeah that's why i was
i would do two one two honestly two one
two that's i feel like i would just
increase the kill cooldown
can't help but go down it's always at
22.5
every time yeah when the game is the
impostor you gotta change the rules to
make it a little bit more fair for the
queen
too good i just wanted to i i just want
one as well so i just like wanted to
figure it out wait who was gonna leave
right now because i have one
uh waiting on the fill was there anybody
who was going to leave right now that's
it
because it was fast because it was so
fast and i'll stick for one
okay all right let's just keep it at
this then uh
213 is what i'm gonna keep it at that's
fine all right let's do it
tweet one three
also thanks everyone for playing the
game anyways
all the time you're welcome thanks for
making it
so much fun
feeling great about this tonight just
crewmates back to back
getting murdered i am getting murdered
and not really seeing anything
suspicious happen i feel like these
people might be pro streamers
or like full-time streamers you know um
like why did you just double back mate
am i about to get mudded by your orange
[Laughter]
butt
okay okay
i'm gonna go sort the lights out and try
not to die
don't okay well that was a bit weird no
then why'd you do that why have you done
that
what what what what
why did northern walk away uh that's my
question
that's my hot little key for the the
chat
the behavior was very strange okay i
never know how to do that that's it i
just have to come back in 60 seconds
beautiful
think adapt is okay
i found the body where where are you
from
in the uh the room with the three
computers the ones where you do all
three things
one after the other nope
oh yeah
i just want to ask northern why did you
walk away from the
electrical when the lights were off you
walked out of the room without fixing
the lights
that is true um that's a technique that
i use because i'm really worried about
being baited
and getting killed so i like to wait for
like another one or two people to show
up so that there's
safety in numbers and then leave
well you already had it at that point
that is true okay
i'll allow it i believe adept is the one
who actually fixed the lights i'm
comfortable clearing a depth this round
um i think it was xqc who cleared it
because i saw northern
yeah i did them okay well i i know the
three of you were there in the room with
me um but adapt i'm clearing you because
i think you're also in
weapons with me right now yeah and i've
not been murdered
thank you i'm by myself at
uh med bay right now what's about to do
sure so what is the three computers is
it met bay or is it tree
wherever the card swipe thing is sorry
i'm not i'm not as good as you guys
the card swipe the card yeah nothing oh
so when you got there was a was the body
already dead or did you kill yes the
body was already dead
there was like there was no one right oh
okay yeah no he's right there because
i'm an admin
and i thought about me in office
and he reported that kill and it was a
free kill um so
if it was a killer you would never
reported it
so who can't go to lights
uh people at clear lights and uh
i'm i did not go to lights i'm like in
the
yeah i was in that light area yeah i'm
going to ski
we got nothing what are you convinced of
nothing great no sarcasm excellent
it's rhythmically though okay
i feel like nothing is happening and we
don't have much information
i hate this one flip it flip flip
yourself
oh my gosh done i'm gonna have to do
this
you love to see it you just you just
have no choice but to love to see it
okay
[Music]
i'm a bit concerned about hassan
did i not do that right
beautiful um i feel like he probably
would have murdered me then
but didn't i do still trust adept we're
doing the same task
and at this point all my tasks are done
and everyone else is miles behind i
well oh no they maybe have it only to
update when yeah they do um
i'm going to follow adept
okay so red teal and lime are together
so lime will tell us yeah
how did you see him do it it's natalie
foreign i saw
him do the murder
it's not possible as i did not do the
murder where
where is this because i mean obviously
it's like left uh
maybe bottom left or middle yeah it's
bottom left
okay felix how did you see them did you
go down cameras i'm on cameras and i see
lime teal and red together as a three
stack
and then one of them is dead one
reported so they know who killed it who
i think it's a bit strange that natalie
didn't from the jump say
it was northern you kind of let everyone
else speak fast
oh no she definitely she definitely
unmuted into a case closed so
oh okay i agree with that yeah
which is what someone would say if they
wanted to gaslight you
into thinking that the other person was
a murderer you bring up gaslighting
where are you i feel like i mean we have
information but none of it is being
conveyed efficiently what has actually
happened and who saw
what wait but why did everyone say it
was lyme who said that
no i said lime lime juice on red or
three stack
and then uh okay so it means they know
one of those two okay well he
and when i got there natalie was stuck
on the door
running up to the body and that's why i
was suspicious at first i thought she
only called it because i was walking up
but if she just saw northern do it it
kind of makes sense because she just got
in there
where the body's at it's weird for me
because i didn't see anything but based
on processing elimination
i'm going to vote after northern a
little bit because i saw like the blood
and like the thing out of the out of the
very corner of my
line of sight and then i had to run
after northern
slander itself wait why did victoria
victoria why did you think natalie
because then everyone was like it was
slime in the beginning
well we got to just keep an eye on
natalie now yo that's what happens here
is we just keep your ass
peeled
oh okay well that's oh that's right my
toss is done well so i'm just gonna
i don't want to follow a murderer like
who cares if i die there really that's
sort of my thing
um
but i the case closed thing
makes it sound like okay i can follow
aoc what are you doing
how are you doing what you've been up to
are you just hanging out
raising money for charity yeah what's up
but the record everyone this is a
charity stream
it might be aoc you know it actually
might be
um because she had conveniently stopped
at the same time that these went off
i don't know about hassani though okay
that's nice
um but she could have just been doing
the fueling task
where did she go is everyone alive yeah
we didn't okay
what you up to what are you what are you
doing
uh yeah this is a charity stream i do
have a uh that i guess
um aoc put together i do have a link in
the uh description on youtube i still
don't really know how to approach that
kind of stuff on twitch so i have not
got it on twitch but
um that is what it's for we are raising
money
look she would have killed me by now
right
i'd be dead right we can all agree that
i would be dead
there are bird sounds in i think she's
fine
i think she's fine so
victoria have you just come from
murdering anyone is anyone dead
victoria what have you been doing
okay sure yeah i'll go fix lights
like i guess aoc could have been playing
a lot oh
that sounds like died right in front of
me literally
no who did it go ahead i was on cams
i pull up on cams i say hmm
i've never i've never done camps on this
map before pull it up
boom i see victoria kill hassan
right there and there was someone right
next to her and i forget the color
but it happened
listen unless you have like some sort of
degree in like communication uh victoria
this is gonna be tough to get out of
there man
i also trust aoc because i finished all
my tasks so i was just kind of following
her around and she definitely did not
motivate me
and i think it was excuse me i'm gonna
admit to it
but um
okay nice swag victoria
[Laughter]
i like killed i like after i like hit q
i was like no
very good very good i think
fcc was looking at her too
well i'm in a dog right now i can't do
anything yeah the lights are off
the lights are off that is true oh oh
okay
it's fine hey good play good luck you're
out to dry
too i did like nothing it's okay it's
okay
i was like hoping you would carry the
team but you didn't
ah beautiful communications didn't pay
off
you you you saved me super
i was doing so many tasks as a ghost not
that i want credit or anything but i was
doing
a lot of tasks i'm just saying
i was yelling at my chance i didn't want
to kill you but like i kept walking past
you and you were alone i was like
i have to kill him that was so vicious
who's leaving i i i'm gonna i'm gonna i
have two people waiting right now
i think it's i think i'm gonna head out
thank you so much for the invite it was
a pleasure thank you for being here yeah
thank you
thank you so much if you if you need one
more spot if anyone
hassan i can actually bow it as well
i've been here for no no no no we we
don't we need
two spots only and i think three people
are leaving right now so okay
oh all right i'm gonna i'm gonna go it
was nice uh
meeting with you people leaving you i'm
leaving also
and um thanks for the invite all right
thanks for coming on dude
and thanks for coming on everybody okay
so natalie left smaller so we need a
third actually we don't need just
two we need three people um hold on
enjoy the rest of your lobby
okay i just sent that invite from the
will
hold on gotta gotta bring them into the
lobby or wait why is will not
big shout out to northern lion thanks so
much love you lots take care
sorry that we mixed you up with uh like
an elderly dog lover
entrepreneur
yeah someone just got like it was very
cute though
i'm sure a lovely human being but not
the lord or the lion that we wanted to
attack
wasn't expecting thousands of
notifications on twitter yes
i woke up like what is going on what am
i even
hey corpse uh here the lobby code
is i'm writing it right now get out
corpse is here
can uh can alex alex can you do the
intro of corpse
when he gets here he's here already okay
he's on mute still no he's in the room
yeah well corpse what's up you there
but he's not in the he's not in the
lobby he's in the voice lobby
i can't hear you he's here i believe he
just said something
yeah he did it must be hard to talk when
you're a corpse to be fair
yeah was that your voice though super
deep like that
get out that's not a real voice
i'm so very jubilant to be here whoa oh
my goodness whoa
well hello there well hello
hello corpse that was that was warm
buttery magic
[Laughter]
yes it is where's your uh
that makes sense
yeah you would have unique skins
i like simplicity minimalism yeah that's
where it's at
well atlanta is the most minimal of all
no that's true okay fine i don't know
wait am i fine yeah you don't have any
she's got an egg on her head and i have
pants on no and she got pants on too
[Laughter]
i think you're already in a spacesuit no
aren't these spacesuits and then there's
stuff on top of your spacesuit
i mean kind of you could slide down this
box right here if you like run down
dude that's sick yeah
extreme sports hell yeah
look at you guys go oh yeah
i mean look i bring all the feedback
back to the team
we'll edit it so you can only just do
this aoc why are you not saving the
planet anymore
is that i am a um i'm an md phd so i'm a
doctor
and i'm a scientist and
my job is to heal people on the ship
except i'm gonna try to heal all the
people who were just killed
but when we land something's gonna go
horribly wrong and you all are gonna
turn into zombies
oh no sorry was that an
influence did you say md phd
md phd so it's uh when you have a
medical degree and a phd
follow-up question are you single
or do you want to bring
[Laughter]
do you want to bring your your fave in
here if you want
uh it was oh who do you think i'm what
do you think i'm talking about you're
you're your favorite it's like who knows
are you trying to cause somebody to have
me he doesn't even have me on discord
i guess you're not his favorite damn
it's like that that hurts maybe he just
didn't see it
all right that's all
i'll dm them i mean we could also play
with with uh without a full lobby while
we're waiting on people
it's true just makes it a bit harder
yeah we do
we just had i just had uh my i just had
someone waiting and he just keeps
dropping in and out of his game thinking
that like we're going to play and then
we're like oh we're going to play one
more
so i feel really bad like will it was
supposed to play and he just keeps like
out of his own game yeah yeah yeah oh
family i feel bad
that's bad but um
that i'm here and i'm very excited to
play among us with them oh we're all
we're all very excited to play with them
um well in the meantime how was
everyone's thanksgiving
um
oh he said yeah he's coming never mind
also do you think he likes bread
you guys will have to ask him i hope so
yes very important question
okay but what's the best type of bread
like you know like is it baguette is it
sourdough
i'm saying i like a salad the wine rolls
oh
i was just about to say the hawaiian
rose i end up eating the
you know no i don't know how to describe
it
it's a little sweet buns the wine rolls
are like cute little buns dessert it
shouldn't even be bread
um i don't know how oh will's in here
okay cool
um hello do you guys need one i need a
girl yeah yeah sorry about that brother
i know
i know you were deep in the rp uh world
you were doing vr stuff but
we just kept pulling you out of it but
here i just sent the code in the in the
general
all right watch out there's fire behind
you
okay so we got we have just need for one
more
and uh if psycho knows down we can fill
the lobby right that's it
that's everybody beautiful yeah but i
don't know what he'll answer
it's all good if he can't do it then we
can we can bring in someone else i'll
just wait because i don't want to have
like people
pulling themselves out of their game and
then that's fair
ask alana about the australian covert
response
what's going on in australia okay so i
am australian
but to be clear i've lived in california
for five years
uh okay but uh the the genuine answer is
like it's going really well
um like my family's having a great time
basically things are back to normal
because they lock the states down
individually so hard so that you can't
like move between them at all um it's
been tough for my grandma because she
can't visit
my my mom and my aunt uh because they're
in different states which really sucks
because she's kind of isolated by
herself in a state that did have an
outbreak it's been pretty sad
like that that is a bummer but uh the
upside is that she didn't get sick and
neither is anyone else in my family and
uh
i think aside from a city called
adelaide we pretty much have no covet
cases right now which
is awesome you love to see it that's
amazing yeah
actually another big shout out to
australia a part of the idea that we
were thinking about
about being able to produce your own
vaccines publicly
is uh australia is relative similar size
to canada
and they're producing um like
30 million doses like millions and
millions of doses
themselves like produced in australia
and
uh but uh in canada one of the tenth
largest economies in the world
we are not able to produce anything in
our own country so well we australia was
also the first country to be able to
replicate it
safely in a lab that's pretty cool we
just don't get enough credit you know
but it as it turns out living in an
environment where everything tries to
kill you you're pretty prepared for
something trying to kill you
also could have said yes um sweet
oh perfect let's bring him in um he also
has the
or you can invite him i think right now
okay can you
okay hello will welcome orb try to
invite him
wait how many people do we have uh we we
we're good on
on both heads now was coming in i i just
uh dmed her too but ladies and gentlemen
uh we are now joined by
uh the the butteriest of voices uh a
corpse
husband and also will neff the man the
myth legend my best friend will nev
is here not quite as buttery a voice but
yeah
that's pretty pretty nice i feel like
you guys would make a great
anime villain duo with those voices
though yes
oh my gosh
it's perfect it's perfect oh yeah you're
his old apprentice it's great i love it
it's a fair warning
where's the humongous anime oh wait i
would i guess i would be in charge of
that
that would be my job okay i was like oh
wait that's me
should we keep doing polos do you guys
like that map or should we go back to
the original one
we haven't done the third one right do
the third we're not doing the
the third one is just terrible wow
wow
it's fine it's like good now okay corpse
oh he's in here all right what's up
what do you think do you like the uh the
third one
what oh my do you like the third room
yeah
that's spooky do you want to do it then
why map you guys want to do the ymap
cool with whatever curse yes you're
allowed to curse okay okay i'll do the y
map
all right you guys asked for this let's
do it oh
let's do it i like it
okay let's do it you guys are lying
i'm writing the code in here right now
gotcha shout out to northern lion
once again um who was
the one who loki kind of started this is
i think he just
shot a shot at uh
big shout outs big shout outs to
northern lion i mean
he failed because you know selfish you
know has to have to take care of
his child
[Laughter]
but uh yeah i i gave you guys a code in
the lobby
oh we're good now
corpse i gotta ask have you always
sounded that amazing or is that like
something you train yourself over time
man i don't sound amazing i
i remember calling myself out of school
when i was 12. so i at least sounded
older then
wow nice nice nice but like ever since i
was younger it's always been like
when i was when i was like 14 it was
like are you 20 and then when i was like
17 it was like are you 25 it just keeps
going up and up no just a lot of
cigarettes
yeah that's your only part two i've
never does your did you
somebody else in your family sound like
you does anyone have
i don't know my family maybe it's like
oh yeah
i'll put that in the in the chat as well
all right thanks
there it is will neff you're an angel
oh that i am i lost all my friday the
13th stuff because i had to redownload
the game which is
sad but
that's definitely now the groundskeeper
all right we're waiting on one last
person i don't know who it is i think it
might be
oh no will's in here who is not in the
game
oh that's me sorry why am i green what's
happened to me
hey question for y'all do you know that
movie oh where i have your color
the people where the guy has a red hat
and he's uh in a submarine
and it's like a really like a cool
director that does these like funky
movies
life equipment oh yeah life aquatic okay
so i am the i'm i'm a life aquatic
i'm the life aquatic guy and uh
basically
i'm on an adventure yeah yeah
yeah i'm i'm currently wearing that
beanie right now like the one
you're referencing yeah so i'm
i'm wearing this are you wearing it as
well in the cake oh no you're not you're
wearing i'm wearing the
i'm wearing like a fan in real life in
real life i see it yeah no i don't know
on a mission and an adventure to seek
out
a wonderful new life to
expand the horizons of humanity
you guys are are you always this
positive both you and a or fear like
i feel like i'm too irony poison like
immediately my mind goes to
like you know terraforming mars yeah i'm
out here like i'ma open the first strip
club
oh my gosh no honestly i think one of
the best parts about like
just like watching people play games is
just the stories that they make up with
it
like you just give them a blank canvas
and they just go wild it's
it's wonderful it's amazing but it gets
pretty cool like a horrible turn or
something
yeah and then you get dogs it sucks
[Laughter]
corbs are you a furry uh
look man i don't answer questions yo
how come you have these little cool
little pets walking around with you
adapt
give me one of those uh he programmed
he had to buy them those are microchips
those are bougie those are bougie
does it give you any options yeah i
heard it asked me to pay money it says
2.99 for a pet
yeah no that's the same for everyone i
think oh okay
[Laughter]
that girls are a gateway to people you
started walking around
and this alien was i agree with that oh
let's do this
okay
i do uh find this map to be pretty
difficult
is all i am saying i still do not know
these people
i did get a text from a friend who
seemed very excited about
the fact that i'm playing with corpse
but i really feel like that's the part
where i am much more a
uh games media than content creators
that i know people in the games industry
but not many people who make
content oh my gosh oh no
ah so
i sadly i walked into this room and i
saw people walk in
and then i walked out to go fix oxygen
and then when i came back in there was a
dead body and i devastatingly do not
remember
who was in there okay okay
i i just walked into that room and
atlanta was already standing there
by the body yeah to be clear i i was
thinking in my head of like who was in
this room when i was in halos before i i
hit report i was like oh no
i don't remember who was in there i mean
yeah yeah because i took myself a couple
of seconds to be like can i recall who i
saw walk in here
and i said your hands like yeah no i
didn't kill anyone i just went to fix
uh oxygen uh i think a depth would have
seen me do that because the depth was
the one who did it
and then i walked straight back in there
what room are we talking about
it's the entrance to reactor the very
bottom like when you have to like press
the airlock to go up
and i really don't remember who's in
there um victoria and i were a top
oxygen i'm the one who fixed the top
oxygen
uh but she's definitely clear for this
kill
um and probably even clear in general
but i don't know yet
adept is also clear jug is also clear
yeah yeah yeah who cleared me that's
legit me
that's you are a duck
at all
i think i think it would be pretty tough
for him to do this kill
but not impossible also paul will he's
he's not a last round
i know
really he just started i i don't know
what else to say like you were already
standing there
you're 100 right like i was standing
over it but it's because i took a few
seconds to be like oh my gosh who was in
this room and then i was like i don't
know and i hit report yeah
um so what do we think then uh
well i was walking up and there was
there was someone near there in the med
bay scanner but i don't remember who it
was
i don't know about that either
so it might be aoc is all i'm saying you
might be
aoc and uh lana are all sauce for this
ill i didn't do a thing
except stand there for a second because
i was trying to figure out who i had
seated that room that is 100
a thing that i did do
but i don't recall at all i gotta pay
more attention i know that's like what
well okay no i am pretty good at this
game but what people say when they're
like pros
is um name the colors out loud
okay well did that get done it did it
did
i'm gonna go do this here right now
ah that's right i always think it's the
counting one six eight
two one nine enter task
completed okay
we gotta go down everybody seems to be
alive and in the same area
victoria are you gonna kill me i don't
like that we're alone down here
it's okay all that was in front of
everyone
where's the body it was something surely
everyone saw that
preventing you from hitting the report
button aoc i was
walking
no i agree she did not kill wanna this
is
this is true but wait were you the one
to find it got into we both did we both
walked up onto it i was like three steps
behind her but she just stood there
[Music]
you got to press the tab button to find
what tasks you're going to do this isn't
a good defense but she really didn't do
it
like my left hand on the tab my right
hand on the directionals
so that when i find something i have to
panic and like
get the mouse over so i i will
be standing over everything really three
seconds every time i find it she does
okay she's not this much of a boomerang
okay
you're a dope human
okay so here's what i think um i'll be
honest i i thought it was serfs
that did this kill it and it probably
still is killing aoc is the second
imposter because surf's immediately
rushed to defend aoc i'm going to go
with aoc on this one or let's go with
cerfs on this one
could be the other one who knows who it
is
that they didn't all see that it seemed
like everyone was right there
you got to vote oh man brutal brutal
right in front of me you know you know i
was just out there trying to figure out
where to go and i was like really
wasting time
like really i'm not gonna say i didn't
deserve to die there that was like 100
i would have killed me um
but i can't do that anyway
uh i it seems so it seems so bold
oh my god i 100 know
a hundred percent know i was right there
it was a hundred percent aoc i'm so
sorry
yeah i'm on the um you just you did it
right in front of me though
right in front of me i don't know if
these people use
uh in the first round because he was
like hanging out on the far right corner
you know what he was doing over there
but i did i did that so i did task man i
tell you
i just trying to make friends why
haven't you guys voted
so i'm just waiting for someone to do
that
for me too and unfortunately a dev got
killed there in the crossbar
i don't feel like we're going to win
this on on tasks though i don't feel
like the chances of that are very good
i still don't know if it's aoc
i have no idea ah
it was aoc a huge bummer
don't worry aoc you'll be alive again
soon we all know what we're doing right
um
or was i wrong the entire game or what
it serves right is that what we're
saying
i think so yeah i think that's what it
sounds like corpse is that what you're
saying
about who we think it is i don't know
man we just voted i appreciate you
taking charge
i mean he's a fellow canadian i feel sad
doing this he's progressive
if i'm wrong then this is very terrible
and embarrassing that i just
took me no we got it but wait let's all
try this on settings
vote for me just to see what happens do
it go down
do it please
what's
[Laughter]
[Music]
so i watched a video on like
sick among us moves and one of them
is what is that
it's a way for everyone to be in a crowd
and then
kill someone and then nobody will know
oh that kills it yeah
kill classic that's true too
but i don't think that play will be
getting in the next compilation
and one mixtape another one
yo that's my hero and when mixtapes i
don't know if anyone else knows about
those
no i know how to do hot sauce wait how
old are you
yo i'm old man i'm 41.
what yeah oh my god
i thought you
the vegetarian lifestyle you know
plant-based that's fast
i'm about to go vegan i'm taking it
trying to keep it healthy you know i'm
29 you i
legit thought you were like i like your
skin
eat myself okay okay okay uh
beautiful we have to go straight here
i feel like i didn't get the fuel though
how are you gonna where did i did i just
have it in my inventory
the lore of this game doesn't even make
sense
you know okay i have to go up through
reacted to laboratory
oh a lot of you just came from there
that's
not ideal
you got it you saw you saw
alex who just passed us it was it was
jugg right
who just passed us yeah through the hall
i'm almost
certain this was jug running away from
this body
so what happened he was doing tasks with
me it's it's not in spawn
it's um i i actually don't
i don't come on because i was looking at
the map okay
i think it was jug jug any defense
no no 100 not i was doing tasks right
off the bat i saw a bunch of other
people doing tasks what tasks were you
doing
uh-huh i was doing the um
there was like a row of buttons and i
have to click them
yeah okay i don't know
it totally happened
i'm sorry man that was that was terrible
dude
[Laughter]
is honestly i
there's i don't know who it is but
there's someone out there that's taking
off
there's gotta be two there's gotta be
two i don't know who they are though
oh boy there's somebody out there though
we got to find them
[Laughter]
the most evasive answers
i don't know who the other one is
um so uh youtube chat is upset
apparently i'm not reading any of it
but i did want to say um people who are
complaining about uh video games being
made political
um or that they don't get their their
space
we haven't spoken about politics this
stream the only people talk about
politics is you
um to the other people in chat who are
annoyed by it just ignore
it like literally just don't even pay
attention like i don't care uh it
doesn't bother me at all um people are
allowed to
to share political opinions wherever
they like but if it's uh bothering you a
lot
just don't engage with it that's cool
uh it's literally just a game of among
us that happens to feature a politician
and we are raising money
to uh i can link i have the link in the
description on youtube but
but oh i thought it was psycho now
okay oh i'm okay it's not aoc it's not
hassan
i i know that now so i can i can narrow
the list i was clearing out leaves
i
[Music]
having said that i think corpse and
uh adapt our services right corbs it was
a death in my stomach
yeah i think so too yeah yeah we went
into reactor i don't know
we popped off a reactor was there
another person there no right
i don't think so it was just us three so
it would have been very difficult for
whoever that was under it's definitely
not corpse i saw
i didn't i didn't see victoria standing
completely i really have no idea
like not doing anything all i know is
jack killed me i'm sorry
oh so it has to be he just said sorry
that's why
i was opening up my chat oh okay no
psycho could never do this right i don't
second it would never
do something like this corbs you're this
like rooney i would like to hear that i
would like to hear that from
yeah i mean i might have a glass of this
interesting place if i was imposters uh
jordan i just said what we're raising
money for it's um
different organizations that are feeding
families communities and around
delivering little liberal places
everyone's okay did you see any
suspicious activity he did check up on
me
maybe to kill you though
um i'm alive right he couldn't get
himself to kill you
i think all right well we gotta vote i
don't think we have enough i think
[Laughter]
[Music]
well that was fast all right you had me
work
nice work hard for imposters
i told you i don't anyway it's it's a
hard map
it's not my favorite out of the three
that's for sure
hey um corpse i got a favor to ask if
you don't mind and if i could just um
say something yeah yeah yeah
could you just say uh vote for me sing
just one time and then i'll just
i'm just gonna use that for multiple ads
um
i'm just joking wait do
do i'm juggling sing and i approve this
message
i promised i would never say things for
people after like three years ago
that i would never be like because
everything and everyone's like you said
this and i'm fine
because i have too much power
we'll do our fake corpse voices for you
yes yes
and you can modulate all of them i will
modulate them that would be
the best corpse that i can do
i feel like this is a decent course it
is
you sound like solid snakes
and not an impostor
that's awesome the best i can give you
is like a steve owen type like kid i
might i'm jack meet sing and i approve
this message
best one that's all i got yes that's
that jug meat you have to use that i use
that
i use that in the campaign yeah it'll go
great people trust australia first i
couldn't use it unless you totally like
gave me like overt and expressed
permission to do so
you can use that um anytime you like
mate
go for oh that's yeah thank you mate i
appreciate that oh
oh oh he used my language
[Laughter]
i you know what there was a time period
like years ago
that i went to australia four times in
three years
from whoa yeah yeah i was like doing
like conferences out there and like
it was a couple of like it's a long
flight but i loved it like i love
australia it's such a cool place
thank you i invented it myself uh yeah i
really appreciate it
recognition for my hard work this is
working out so well
for another oh boy yeah should we go
should we
did it it was too late
uh i was talking i was talking on my
stream because so
um we've been fundraising for like food
pantry and eviction defense
and we just passed 41 000 oh wow
oh nice that's amazing wow
great job congrats shout out to everyone
who's out here helping people
in the holiday season and everything
that's having a tough time so
that's awesome absolutely oh yeah
yeah super cool how could we share the
link in our chats
i put mine in the description um hang on
like i'll give you the link there just
like
is it true that you're oh my god i mean
cyberpunk or is that a meme people keep
telling me this in the chat
i am indeed in cyberpunk yes okay so
that's not two for two okay because the
other one was like what
ask alana about australia and kovic shut
down so i was like oh no i'm going to
ask her another question she'd be like
i'm not a cyberpunk i am in cyberpunk
yes
that's what that one is i'm so very
excited i'm very excited about
the sniper program yeah i mean
you know a lot of delays still sort of
scared it won't come out but hopefully
it does
uh just have a test very excited
yeah that's that's game development
yeah but that looks like my post my
post-apocalyptic heart
really looks forward to that i think
it's gonna be cool uh yeah official
alana okay second question um
second question for you uh did you were
you a part of god of war you say you're
santa monica studios
i'm a writer at santa monica studio yeah
so you were a writer on god of war
so i'm a writer at santa monica studio
yeah
that's all i can say is happening
okay cool that's that's sick i just i
have an axe i have the kratos acts like
right above my head it's a great hey
leviathan acts good stuff
yeah it's so sick very cool
okay um i'm gonna stop asking questions
now about video we're gonna get
time down yes let's go let's go
yeah uh how are you doing kuno are you
good
oh yeah just uh just just uh yep
did you get fun did you have fun that
last round was it was that good
uh check it out i didn't do so well but
i think you did
you did great you definitely convinced
corpse that you weren't impossible truly
thought it wasn't you
everyone oh thanks corpse uh oh okay uh
genuinely i really
let's learn let's do another one then if
aoc doesn't have a lot of time
all right yeah let's roll let's go let's
do it let's see oh so seriously forty
thousand dollars whoo
yes yeah it's amazing
just oh cremate all night so good
okay this is just just the happiest i've
ever been wait was it not right there oh
no it's reactive okay never mind
nope okay i'm completely alone so i sort
of feel safe going to reactor right now
is what i'm gonna say i might get killed
on the way out wait what wait what
someone's already in here that was
decontaminating wasn't it someone's
already in here
uh
hey adapt how are you
okay you know just keep doing whatever
it is that you're doing
oh did they both
huh nobody vented to get any of them
okay
okay
seems fine there's three of us like you
know both whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa
okay oh no
um there's two people dead um
okay what are we doing where is it i
walked into secundo dead
just just savagely murdered and i saw
someone running right into a vent but i
just cannot
remember the color but i just i was just
shocked at the brutality of the murder
and uh okay where was it
it was uh how shocked were you
i was shocked i did not expect to see it
it was just it was just laying there and
i just thought like
cicuna just seemed like a nice guy and
just seemed so chill and then anyways
okay but there's not someone running
into the event though right afterwards
uh but where was it uh
like what part of the map is it near is
it like near it it was down it was the
same
right at the bottom of where you enter
reactor like right at the bottom way the
first airlock is
nothing to the left and i know that
because aoc
and adept and i had all done tasks in uh
the top of reactor and we're just
walking down
saw the body just as jag reported it so
aocd
south and left it was south and left
okay so wait wait we can we
okay let's say it's not jug me and it's
not a self report because you panic
because you saw people coming
let's see that that's not the case uh
who was the three people you said alana
you
adept and who aoc we're all together 100
they did not do this
okay so it's victoria corpse and will
neff and corpse hasn't talked at all but
will never
doing corpse voice will was also not
that's funny that you mentioned both
corpse and i
because we saw each other
doing my tasks right now and i can see
everybody so
okay no one's talking about it okay did
anyone see the surfs though that's the
other question too
no no no no i don't know it has to be
victoria but process of elimination but
you guys can go whatever you want to do
if willing
which wouldn't make any sense okay well
i shouldn't have voted for victoria then
oh wow oh wow oh
wow
i can't vote because i'm glitched oh my
gosh okay
okay you guys know guys
oh gosh i just didn't think anybody
would do anything i should have voted to
skip
that is my bad i make mistake what do
you want me to buy
there's gonna be this c two what was
this drawn by a child
oh it was oh i'm sorry
and then go to storage just go to
storage
did you just kill someone over here
adapt or i don't think you did i think
you're fine i think we're all okay
i think i think
he was the one who did it that makes
sense yeah
yeah no that checks out what is this
what is this what what what
water plants
i've never done that before aoc see me
i'm dead please
i'm right here oh oh
oh no that checks out
yeah so
that's cool uh
[Laughter]
wow uh big bubba but
happens to the best of us
[Music]
all i could say was i was just beside
corpse and i thought he was all right
because we were just hanging out
together for a sec
uh yeah wow and where'd you come from
before you met up with me in corpse
who was that is that is that adept yes
um and i was drawing in the northward
direction
and then i came into a into a room and i
just hung out there with corpse for a
bit
and then you know corpse adept here's
what i have to say
i'm getting i'm getting a vision in my
head and it was of
me and jug in cafeteria with a certain
alana
and then me and will ran to decontam
and when we came back it was only jug
at all except dead on the floor
no i don't know i don't know i didn't
remember the color of the killer wait
guys i have a ouija board out right now
they're going to tell me
i'm not serious i can see the dead chat
i'm not even joking
oh where were you um
i was top left reactor
top left reactor it's me corp's
boyfriend
i'm thinking corbis's boyfriend i'm
thinking will neff no it's not
his boyfriend he's corpse husband i'm
corpse boyfriend
where were you alex i was
so i was up by that little like flower
in uh in the
oh my god you split it we'll left i'm
going well now no i think it does have
the ouija board
we should have listened before we lost
we freaking lost
yeah we actually tied them split corpse
you
tied it the ouija board wouldn't tell me
who it was they weren't telling me
i think he knows
i think he knows he i i surely he read
that
surely um
i could do tasks you know i'm pretty far
behind but i also like to witness
murders and i do want to see what aoc
does
is the thing all right
wait did we get it off oh my god we got
it off we could still win we just played
there was sweat pouring off my brow as i
was being stalked
around the map i was like a professional
athlete bobbing and weaving
in and out of the cafeteria to stay
alive we we have to not split this vote
i'm i'm open for suggestions but it's a
hundred percent
will nothing 100
he was chasing me so bad i like he's
laughing at how much he's spinning the
story
a hundred percent well enough he's all
down his political skills
will death
i'm consulting i'm consulting the dead
people still give me a moment
okay consulting the spirits
all the way i need to
tell me i'm telling you it was well left
will never be so good at this game
i don't know if you can see it though so
good at this game i've been dead first
twice the last two rounds
but he might only be able to see
victoria not sure
it's if you're if you're not going to
vote well enough you're you're going to
lose this game i'm telling you right now
it's well enough oh you can only speak
to him
that's so funny
it's so hundred percent will and the
name is called the will
i i think it's aoc because i saw her run
down don't start the vote again
don't do this
no no no
come on
[Music]
there's still another one left right
don't they lose now one more
oh my god
someone screenshot this quickly
screenshot this
it's gonna be an aoc victory in the
future this is prophetic
you have to aot president prime minister
victory right here corpse did you throw
the game because i'm good at your voice
be honest are you that that's exactly
what i did
yes the rise of the course boyfriend
putting on a bunch of rings okay yeah
corpse how did you how did you see the
dead what was going on yeah no
there was there's some gameplay it was
only victorious
the problem was ron was the ghost he got
was a developer of the game and i can't
encourage cheating
in the game i'm a pilot
you can only see the dev uh you can only
see like the victoria's chats is that
what happened
i could see that yeah
okay
game we added another 10 grand oh my
gosh
that's incredible you're murdering
people
dollars for food pantries and eviction
defense
she's murdering people and also saving
lives in the real world
um amazing i got a question for you
do you are you planning on doing
anything for georgia like what's your
what's your
what's our goal here
so right now we actually did some some
other fundraising about a week or two
ago
straight to grassroots georgia um
community organizations because you know
i think
one of the things that we learned in the
election is that it's really these
grassroots groups
that are doing the work that that are
like registering people and doing
political education
so um we've been fundraising for them
but also
there's a lot of ways you can give your
time so you can write postcards
um especially since covet is crazy right
now and
it's not always the most helpful thing
to show up in person unless
a group asks you to um that you can
write
postcards and reminding people when the
election date is and when the
registration date is
so there's a lot of organizations
there's galio there's first fight
um there's uh there's like
there's there's just a there's just a
bunch of of organizations so those are
also available
um for us too to help lincoln project
no we want to support like actual
progressives
my mom liked that one she's laughing
when you said that
yeah that's that's awesome um yeah
it's a it's a pretty it's pretty
significant uh it's a pretty significant
election we got two senate seats you can
if you're if you're frustrated everybody
if you're frustrated by the fact that a
second stimulus never came
remember that it's as much as i am
critical of nancy pelosi and as much as
i'm critical of the democratic party as
a whole usually
uh the reality is the the people that
are holding up this aid
that is uh a necessity at this point
it's been a necessity for
months now people that are holding up
this aid are the republican parties as a
whole
who see even conceding to nancy pelosi
not aoc nancy pelosi uh
as a as a burden for themselves they
don't want to get primaried out by a
a more conservative republican and
that's why they're holding up this uh
stimulus conversation
and ruining the lives of millions of
people 12 million people
are about to uh their their unemployment
insurance is expired right
yeah yeah it's expired so if you want a
stimulus
this is this is something that we need
to focus on yeah
i mean we flip these two seats we get a
15 minimum wage in the united states
like that's how that's life transforming
because in
in new york and in other states you know
i'm and i don't say that just
you know for me because in new york city
we've passed a 15
minimum wage in in the city boundaries
but we flip these two senate seats
there are places where the minimum wage
is extremely low
you know and um people are making seven
dollars an hour
if we flip these two senate seats we
double
people's income overnight if they're
working a minimum wage job
like that is how significant these two
seats are so
it's so important that we turn out it
will transform people's lives if we're
able to do this and you know
i think it's going to be really awesome
yeah absolutely and we know and we know
from the
past election that just happened that
uh these progressive policies no matter
what people try to say
are incredibly popular uh even in a
place like florida where
donald trump won the electoral college
vote more people voted for
uh increasing the the minimum wage to 15
more people voted for that as a ballot
measure
than for joe biden or donald trump so
policies are so popular that they're
they're they're more popular than the
candidates themselves
so you know yeah as a foreigner
the crazy low minimum wage in the us has
always been
so bizarre to me i think when i was like
14
i was earning 15 an hour at mcdonald's
uh because australian minimum wage is
you know we don't have tips no one
relies on tips to make money it's it's
something that like
living in the us and finding out that a
waiter can make six dollars an hour is
incomprehensible to a lot of other
countries
i mean some places it's two two dollars
an hour
yeah and then you live up to pips yeah
so i was
um yeah so about three years ago i
was waitressing and i bartended that was
like what i was doing right before
becoming a member of congress and um and
my paychecks the thing is too is that
they
they tax your tips and they take it out
of the paycheck so
i didn't know that for a week
and for a week's worth of wages and
it'll be two dollars on my pay stub
there would be 50 cents on my pay stub
because you get paid so low
but you also get kind of your taxes
taken out of your claim tips now if you
make
enough money on tips that's fine but in
a lot of places
it it doesn't you know it doesn't even
out
and so you're when you live off of tips
and you don't make and you're making two
dollars an hour
it's you have an extremely precarious um
income and so it's very different than
making a minimum
a living wage and then having tips on
top of that living page
yeah and for those of you who are
wondering how we could have such
uh almost inhumane policies it's a
consequence of those who
have a lot of money specifically
dismantling
uh any sort of labor protection that
could have advocated for this sort of
thing
in the united states of america uh
programs or think tanks like alec
and uh and numerous other ones that are
funded by billionaires such as the koch
brothers or i guess the koch brother now
who is now doing a media tour saying
he's uh apologizing for how polarized
the country is
uh things like that are are directly
funded by billionaires
that and who lobby politicians to make
sure that the
minimum wage is not a living wage
so you know just uh remember that
someone here is from australia right i
was going to say australia's got 20 to
25
minimum wage doesn't it yeah that's me
so i'm not i'm not positive of exactly
how much i earned when you know we can
start working at i think it's 14 and
nine months thirteen in nine months um
and i definitely earned over ten dollars
an hour but we also get
extra time on a saturday and then you
get double pay on sundays
um on public holidays it's usually
double time and a half so like
double plus point plus half like it's
there's just the amount that you get
paid
even as a teenager is higher than a lot
of people trying to support their
families in the us and it is something
that is like you know being foreign
incomprehensible it's so
hard to fathom um that people can get
paid so
little for you know and stuff like
waiting and retail can be really
difficult jobs like it everyone throws
that away like it doesn't matter or it's
not important but that stuff can be
extremely stressful
it's also an extremely important uh it's
it's our primary industry whether we
like to admit it or not like the service
industry is a huge part of
of our our labor economy at this stage
and and unfortunately everything is also
moving towards gig economy jobs as well
and one of the most significant things
that happened in california was prop 22
where uh basically tech giants
uh completely eradicated any chance that
uh uber employees and postmates
employees and all these employees of
other
big tech companies could ever unionize
or even get
uh employer status if they hit a certain
amount of hour like full-time employment
hours
and therefore these companies no longer
have to pay them
you know higher wages they can't they
can't advocate for higher wages
and they can't even get benefits so if
you're an uber driver in the state of
california
uh you can't unionize you you are not
designated as a as an employee
and if you for example get covet god
forbid uh
then you know and something bad happens
to you and your decommission like
you're not getting any um you're not
getting any compensation
for that there's no there's no benefits
package that would help you or your
family
uh anyway before the lobby ends though i
gotta start it
all right now let's motor each other
okay good stuff bye everyone
last game okay proposition 22 coming to
uh
your state as well probably okay
i have not had uh impostor once also i
just as a foreign i don't have that much
to say about
about u.s politics generally
okay back to
playing a video game
i'm going to go up the top of reactor
again
i can't believe aoc was the one that i
vouched for her
i vouched for her and that's how i was
repaid
she totally vented in there though i did
have that thought because how would she
have gotten there so fast i'm stupid is
basically what's happened here but um
also wow okay someone's gonna help me
immediately huh
i mean there's no point waiting or doing
this yet i should just do this one first
because shouldn't i see that
oh oh they did it okay everyone's here
my bad
i thought that one person would come and
then i would oh my bad that's not gonna
look good for me
either way it's done uh i haven't seen
this before
look at these updates
hello hello oh wow right after i
right after i left the the radioactive
room
i found jug meat on the other side dead
corpse it's your course should we all do
courses
we should
okay so well you're telling me that
sorry well you're telling me that you
found out
like this exactly when i started going
towards
the north of the map after i left the
containment i found jug dead
okay got it okay by the switchy board i
want to hear what aoc
has to say i was by the office
you just sound like you're whispering
um admiring the exercise balls
and did the wiring okay
well it's not a lana for this kill uh
probably for both this is a fact why do
you say that
because i went up to the reactor and she
was the only person that was next to me
on the right side after we popped off on
the reactor
yeah i just did the thing where you saw
it it was my first time doing it
actually different types of like fossils
into different boxes
yeah can we figure out who wasn't in the
reactor because it might have been them
i was on the left side yeah there were a
lot of
victoria then it's like no one was not
there
i was like i'm sorry i was with
wait someone's saying that cycuno wasn't
there and someone is saying that he was
there
oh no i i definitely was not in the
reactor so it could have been me
oh man i have no idea
well skip the vote
[Laughter]
he wouldn't hurt all righty
you think that i have to do this no i
keep reading this map wrong
it's really stupid uh
we have up here and then this okay cool
not that much left hope i don't get
killed
trying not to get killed y'all running
away from a dead body or you're just
someone dead no aoc is fine please don't
kill me please don't kill me
congresswoman aoc seven seven eight
seven nine boom
[Music]
cool cool cool office
will
okay what i have i have something in
here what is it
really okay this
this this this
that why does that take up so much of
the screen
i can i have an ultra wide monitor and i
can clearly see everything else
okay this is absurd
welcome oh you're gonna do that okay i
thought you were gonna why
why did you think i was gonna do that
you think i vented on
um so corpse fenton why do you why do
you think i think you went to them
you saying you're telling me club spent
it is that what happened standing on the
vent the entire time and then i was like
all right i'll walk off of it now and
then right when i walked off lights came
back on and i was like oh no it looks
like i vented
but if like to be fair if i would have
vented the vent would have popped open
even in the dark yeah he would have seen
the animation so i think you're good
so you vented no no he didn't invent it
um he he did look it did look like he
just came off the vent
um and that is precisely what well
that's not the only reason why i hit the
hit the button i also thought maybe
could a kill could have popped off in
the light
um like while the lights were off but uh
also because
corpse was uh at the edge of deacon tam
early on and it looked like he was maybe
either faking a task on the wire
on the bottom of the contam and i never
saw him in that trajectory going to
lights
that's why who trajectory i did wires
and then i ran up to lights
yeah i just we were on the same path and
i never saw him but the lights were off
but so we can't it i just wanted to
prevent
another kill oh
lights lights went off um i
of course was doing wires i run back uh
to the lights i don't see corpse on the
pathing and we're like
you know very close to one another we're
supposed to be very close to one another
um but i do see as soon as the lights
are uh
coming back on corpse coming directly
off the vent i didn't see the
vent pop up though yes definitely could
have i mean
it probably wasn't him and nobody's dead
who did you vote for okay
i'm
since everything is popping off if we
hit to seven if we hit 71 before the
game is over
um then i'm going to play another round
what happened everyone just reacted as
though some oh gabe's broke
what's happened what's wrong
amazing i'm coming from the dead to see
that what happened
congratulations
[Music]
quick that's amazing
all right game on i don't know what
happened because i muted too soon and i
different too soon and now i am confused
great that didn't work out in my favor
brilliant
oh they had 75 000. that's insane
oh my god wow that's that happened so
fast that's amazing um i can't believe
that uh you took that opportunity to
murder me
no one's gonna find me for ages out
there
also i sort of trusted will because we
were alone together
this stupid thing took two stupid long
stupid ridiculous
okay
um
that's my toss done so i know
nothing from ghosts will kill me
it could be corpse did he vent i don't
know
it seems like a person who's doing a
task
no lucky game
[Music]
i saw aoc kill cycuno through the
contamination
no way i'm glad we found the killer
easy
okay wait i would like to propose a deal
snitch on your partner right now and we
won't vote you
already voted here nothing oh never mind
no he's just lying right okay so
what also also victoria is victoria
was with me uh up in reactor and she
didn't off me
so wait so who i'm gonna say it's real
because he
absolutely never it absolutely was not
me i didn't even know that you could
kill people through doors
you can't kill people through a door you
can see through the door and i saw you
just blast
icuno it's okay you'll know for next
round no
it didn't he's lying
i used to think about it i can't
if you slandered a congresswoman i'm
gonna be so disappointed you will
he did though that was rough
oh my gosh absolutely brutal
okay is it corpse though that's my
follow-up question did you vent fam
that's what i'm trying to figure out
what do you no that was weird surely
you're gonna kill someone
it does seem like it might be him
done it
we're being honest that was strange
behavior up there
think you might have you might be right
[Applause]
that was
do you want to do cold map or do you
want to do first map like the the space
ship again
uh you know what while you're deciding
that just a quick random heads up
so we have this thing like the the
national news which is like the the
channel that
it's a cbc it's a public broadcaster and
it's like a pretty well watched
and it plays like the headlines of the
day so this game
just made like the national news this is
like a pretty big deal
oh hell yeah cool i think it's it's
probably because of colt's husband's
voice right
that's why we made it yes yeah probably
probably before
okay i heard the cbc saying that uh
corpse doesn't endorse jug meat thing
he's doing an anime music video for jug
meat
[Laughter]
this is not as amazing as the 75 000k
raised
that's so so cool so incredible
really i'm gonna drop the link again
here we go i got another one before
quick because then my internet's like
yeah i gotta eat so
i think everyone one more pretty much
last game last game one more game
one more game one more game all right
all right so what do you guys want to do
the last map should we go back to the
first map that we did the space i'm
gonna say the first one because i think
all the new players have not played the
fast map
since we started first
let's do it let's do it awesome
let's understand the game neff will neph
is now enough
forcibly disconnected okay
are you no i don't know that's what your
thing says in the lobby
no i'm not in there someone else someone
else leaked
oh okay it is not letting me host the
game for some reason i don't know what's
going on
okay let's have never mind i got it i
got it number one okay i will by the way
you are devious you are a devious killer
yeah yeah
wow oh yeah i know he's he's um
i like him i like
yeah i saw someone vent right next to me
i ate his liver with some parma beans
and a nice candy
it was really hard to not read this
particular quote out loud i wanted to so
bad
i'm not doing it yeah yeah it looks like
a word almost
yeah yeah 4 20 69 can't believe it
it's like how you doing no no oh uh just
just
chilling um thanks for having me thanks
for coming on man
always a great addition to any group
saikuno
the the myth the legend the plants
oh i was gonna say the same thing about
yeah they you give off plant vibes for
sure yeah
yeah when i hear a corpse i want to
think of plant comfort
of course all right i'm
firing it off last round let's go let's
go let's go last one let's do this
hi cbc hi mom
are we like live on that right now like
this is live broadcasting the stream now
probably not yeah pretty much
i have not been imposter even one time i
have done a lot of stupid plays
as the innocent because i don't know
these people
but zero imposter
i'd love to see it you will love to see
it
looks like your nose a bit sauce to me
right now
i am going to put that out there and
this is a stupid play
oh okay
um corpse neff why were you following me
like that
i was doing tasks but i was trying to
stay in the clump especially in this map
and then i went and did
leaves and the lights went out and i
didn't see the body that you reported
but my report came up
so it must have been right now that
makes sense
so we just walked up on a body together
it was in cafeteria
yeah in one part of cafeteria
right side but it was depressed so i
didn't see actually just just from a
game
just from a game theory perspective
because there's only one body
and that corpse was in front of you
cycuno if i was the
other imposter i probably would have
killed you to double and avoid people
following it unless you did it
no because i'm saying the corpse was in
front of us so it would have to have
been the other killer
who killed them because i was behind
psycho when we were yours you're going
to be
no no no it wouldn't have been on
cooldown because i one
imposter has the same kill cooldown as
the other imposter
if i was behind you and the body was in
front of you then the other imposter
would have had to kill it
which means that elimination instant
reported it they're they're saying
all right that makes sense
it's like you know was will behind you
or between you and the body
yeah i'm willing to skip um let's let's
go now everybody
you guys
[Music]
that's the beauty of democracy
wait but if you're the killer then okay
the beauty of democracy
literally nothing to say literally
nothing to comment
i was just out trying to do weapons you
know
beautiful who did that adept did that
there are enough people in here that
this is a good time to get these tasks
out because i hate electrical
because electrical is a murder zone
please no please no not cops please no
oh corpse neff that's confusing
he doesn't seem like he's going to kill
me
the weirdest thing about this set of
games has been that i've never been able
to clear anyone
like i just constantly think everyone is
evil
not comfortably like even when i tried i
was wrong
okay
oh victoria yeah it's
it it has to be it has to be victoria um
okay so here's what happened um victoria
and i
were running from storage down to
shields
victoria runs to aoc's body and turns
around and starts running right at me
and then i got the report
like i don't why wouldn't you report it
wait no i didn't see aoc's body what
i have you didn't have an important
flash on your screen in her body i have
an additional thing for victoria
i have additional information for
victoria i was already sussing her
before
you even said victoria because um cycuno
and i
are running uh near electric
saikuno goes to the fuel tank
lights went off and of course when
lights went off i was like alright well
time to go fix the lights
and the only person i saw that went into
lights
was cycuno out of that pair and uh they
were right next to the electric and it
was really suspicious that she didn't do
that will was also there too but he came
after
someone locked the door on i'm convinced
i voted
she just she ran right up to the body
and then i came
victoria what is your defense honestly i
wasn't paying attention at all because i
was trying to tell chat about game
development
oh did you notice the lights were off
victoria this is what is known as
meta gaming victoria no no
game development yeah a big no no in
among us
i don't know what to vote for so i'm
actually going to skip
that's my choice here i'm insulted
oh there it goes anyway we'll skip we'll
skip too
interesting i did i didn't think that
was convincing but
really yeah same
not out here trying to kill innocence
you know you know what i'm saying
okay
i don't think we have visual cues on so
i don't think
they're gonna see so much in admin okay
okay could i get scanned
mayhaps but then if i lure the wrong
person
you know this game is a lot harder when
you play with people you don't know
because i don't know how they play i
don't and then that's the one that you
walk away from
then everything i have to do is in
stupid admin
somebody's on cams is anybody in here
no it's risky okay
that's how we do
wow
so good at this game wow
i never would have even guessed oh nice
job
big congrats this is awesome well played
well played time dude i i i'm devastated
yeah i thought about it but it looked
like a good chance i just took it
i was already trusting her that worked
so perfectly
i'm what i'm sorry everyone what what a
good boss
everyone turn on each other i was like
what how is this happening i'm just
watching it
as a ghost yeah yeah it was pretty
interesting
i mean she did she did actually do what
i said she didn't
see they're saying you raised 105k
we just what we just broke a hundred and
four oh my gosh
oh my goodness thank you everyone
that's absolutely amazing how many how
many games does that mean then
we live here now i'm definitely gonna
play
at least one more i mean i feel like
that's only safe okay
sorry i keep like screaming every one
but we're gonna ride with you
people ride with you i like
i mean i'm just i so many people i mean
the way
i see it is like if if we raise like
thirty thousand dollars for meals for
people in
a game like yeah i'm gonna play another
one that's true
that's just me i know a lot of you guys
have been on this for a while but
i'm down and if you if you guys want to
pack it up i have no
life i'll be here as long as you're here
i can do one more
time
well i accidentally just put the room
code in the chat so
they can't join because we're full but i
was trying to copy and paste the donate
link and i just put the room coded
instead
don't crash the server everybody don't
put it on yeah
[Laughter]
oh my gosh all right let's go let's go
let's get out of here don't crash the
game
let's go do this there a number that if
you hit you're going to play
one more game on top of everything else
200 i mean i don't want to like i'll
play
backgammon with you hassan if you still
want to play but
i just want
i just i just feel bad and keeping him
we can do something
baby is there
a number is there a number
okay um let's see i mean they just did
you know we got it up to annie because
they just did 30 000.
and so that's incredible in that one
game if we can do
50k if we do 50k
in this game then i'll i'll play
something i'll just like keep on
streaming okay
this is so cool this is so cool
this is like bonkers but i mean it's it
the last game was bonkers too so
i'm already donating as we speak you
said the number
let's hit it let's go would you say 50k
50k
yeah all right let's see
let's see all right are we ready
all right let's roll mate let's keep
going all right all right
yeah right great job last round corpse
yeah
i thought you were never coming back
oh oh that was an accident there we go
okay
don't kill me please don't kill me
i would like to not die thank you
so much you know electrical
not my favorite place to be
i don't i just don't feel safe i just
been dying a lot
no this isn't going to work i'm going to
get
killed in electrical and it's gotta suck
this one's quick
and i think this one's also quick is it
not please please please
okay
i did all my tasks in there oh what
happened that
rough oh wow okay
okay no i can i can vouch for will neff
oh okay so the body is in
uh storage the you'd have to walk
left up to electrical um i did see surf
walking in the direction that would be
away from the body and the report thing
comes up so far away from a dead body
um what happened
i think i did because
i saw victoria running down in storage
while lights were stopped
not going to storage and i ran to
electric
who walked in electrical last i think it
was me like just right now i just walked
in
i'm i'm also going to have no idea what
happened list of innocent people
him him and will never both in a room
doing activities with me
well that was everyone's electrical
right why didn't you
turn left to the lights i mean surf you
walked out of the
i just walked right out of the room
the room with the body okay so atlanta
you're you're the one okay you're the
one with the egg all right so you were
coming in the opposite direction that i
was coming from then when we both saw
each other
yes correct i'm saying you walked away
from the room the body was in
and i walked away who wants it to go
reporting self-report this could be a
self-report
how does that work i'm telling you you
walked away from storage
which is where the body is and you just
admitted
that i came from the other direction um
do you understand what's happening you
get what you're saying that how it
doesn't make sense
but do you understand
i'm skipping this food
yeah it's hard to say right now is it
though
do you understand what his defense just
didn't make any sense dude we just who
do we vote for
we have voted okay okay fine yeah
vote me off great it doesn't matter why
did you vote
all right but if defense didn't make any
sense i don't okay well
all right okay okay it wasn't convincing
enough
all right you better watch
he was walking away and then he was like
oh you walked in the other direction
it was you what no that's not how it
works
this one done
security sure i'd love to
that i don't i just don't know how
nobody picked up on
that being stupid um of course i could
be wrong
but he it didn't
i thought he was fine because of the
medbay situation
i thought that corpse was going to be
fine because
yeah no that's that's how they get you
that is how they get you
still though other dudes logic didn't
make any sense
all right i found alana's body
in cams oh no there that that's that was
my biggest
series did anyone see sirs it's a serfs
sorry sir serves no no yeah go ahead
every every one of you
vote me off right now no no no no no no
no no
chill chill hold on he is above med bay
right now
he's above med bay or or past it right
now i just saw him go that way
does anyone know where adept was the
entire round
uh cams
i was bottom right i passed corpse
and jug up on my way didn't see your
comments
i did not see that coming i can clear a
dub for this one
that's why corpse went for surfs there
it is victoria i didn't want to kiss her
again because i felt bad because we keep
going
for her five thousand left until uh 150
k
oh are you still oh no wait are we just
hitting we just hit 150
150 oh my god
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i'll say this hey i've only got 35
seconds left then if you're all voting
for me but i will say this
i i'm not great at this game i don't
contribute a lot in terms of
being able to help you but i will say
this i am not the imposter so for those
of you who survive
you are about to like think of whoever
was the one accusing me first
that's probably who it is right i'm
trying i'm trying to help you win
i'm trying to help you win i know i'm
going out i know i'm going out but i'm
not the
end i'm not the imposter and i want your
teammates
i feel really bad again
i still want you to win good luck
everyone oh my god i feel so bad now
that was rough man his
because what happened was he came
through here
and i came this way and then i walked up
and there was a dead body right here so
they must have gone out that way
that my point is that he was like well
alana you were coming from the opposite
direction yeah where the body was not
and he was like it's a self-report he's
like but you saw me come from where the
body wasn't
it didn't make sense i'm sorry dude i
it didn't make sense
which you know you could just put it
down to do not haven't played the game
much or whatever
i just feel like i gave corpse too much
power
and i don't think corpse needs more
power i think that i have given him
just i handed him the dub on a silver
platter is what i did
it's not good it's not good
all right finish my toss and then i'll
find someone to follow that's the plan
that's the plan it's like oddly quiet
out here
yeah good cool
um corpse victoria anyone
yes he's okay nope it's the real
see
he gets people to trust him he's gonna
kill him
he gets people to trust him
victoria is not as good hmm
why did he what are you victoria what
are you doing
i mean she works on the game i could be
completely wrong they should just be new
strats
he's so tidy
okay okay
go ahead corpse
yes i'm on cams i'm watching everyone
move
then corpse comes into the room
and there were two other people there i
forget
who just got killed adept maybe and
i'm like oh i'm safe there's three of us
in here
then he has the audacity
to not just murder right in front of me
that's
really weird but go right into the vent
right in front of me this is really
weird
why is it weird because none of that
happened
i was just with the mid lights a second
ago
wait what did you say corpse you were
you were at the lights a second ago
okay we were i was in storage with all
of them yeah and then we
ran past lights went off i saw kim's up
walked past cam's i'm currently in
cafeteria but there's no one here
um it's just this is such a defensive
weird
story to come up with like that's true
bro because it's true
what no i don't even know what was going
on in front of you
this was the plan this was the plan all
along he was going to do something so
ridiculous
that i uh aoc
at what point did you stop using the
cams so that you could see corpse do all
those things i'm in cafeteria so yeah
here's what it was no here's what it was
i was on the cams and i was on the
canvas for like a minute like i don't
know why they all believe it
seems so solid to me so here's the thing
so i was on the cams
and then i saw on kim's you walking in
and so i
what have you done
okay victoria it's all you fam
good luck good luck is all i'm going to
say i don't know that you got this
this is going to be a tough one oh okay
yeah
sorry yeah yourself now
she could have just outed herself and
she did not
i don't think she did she's fine
what's the plan victoria
you got some murdering to do
okay explain why that's crazy i didn't
want it i didn't want to give that too
much time because i feel like if they
doubled we'd lose yes my my math on that
i think is correct
um i really don't think corpse did that
i was following him for like
90 of the round
okay well go ahead i'm just saying i
didn't i don't think it was corpse i was
following it like
hold on so here's the here's the thing
it does make sense if
uh aoc is on cams she sees corpse walk
into cams she gets off cams
and you saw a body is that what you said
okay so let me tell you what no no no no
here's what happened so
so i was on cams i see corpse walking to
the room and so i get off the cams and
then adept
also i guess was like walking in behind
corpse and so since it was the three of
us it was me
corpse and adept i was like oh okay like
we're
safe because it's the three of us and
then corpse kills the depth right in
front of me and runs down to the vent
can i ask you a question how long did it
take you to report
it took me a couple actually because
what happens that i was chasing corpse
down to the vent
and so then i had to walk up time i'm
voting aoc
yeah that's a terrible okay that that
last part does not make sense why would
you chase
murderers no i don't know i got caught
up in the moment
but then again i don't know i i don't
know vigilante
justice no one's even suspicious it's
real
i mean it is what
yeah because you're saying because
you're saying it's not cool
covering for him confused
all right i was on mute the whole time
all right
aoc 100 aoc i'm so sorry to say this
100 percent wait wow
that is so so sad we didn't want
unbelievable well it has to be either
corpse or aoc anyway so that's a 50 50.
so now we have one killer left
right it has to be i hope so yeah oh my
gosh oh shoot
she didn't even have to do anything
that is insane how many people do you
have to kill now do your tasks everyone
is it just one
it might just be one
all right i always forget the math if
it's one or two like i should i should
learn that better
but what is everyone doing oh you're
pretending to have done your tasks i see
victoria i see
you're not gonna sabotage nobody's gonna
sabotage anything here
yeah you should do that why didn't you
do that
what why didn't you
why did you not do that that's confusing
then you would have just you could have
just meant it
is it not victoria am i wrong about who
it is is she actually do a task is that
what's happening
i'm confused
i'm confused is anybody dead is anybody
dead oh my god is they be dead
okay no one's dead no one's gonna know
we're good who has tasks
what is good i just went to the
electricity thing
i pushed it up i was in there i did it
so it's not me
ah shoot i have no idea of
but he kept on avoiding me and i was
avoiding him and then he ran past me
he didn't kill me so corpse is legit i
think i'm okay
maybe it's whoever whoever is the killer
is is really apparent no it's not me
whoever is the killer
is very apprehensive at this stage not
even popping off like any doors or
anything
they did one door victoria's the only
one who i honestly when i saw
victoria come down to admin and i saw
corpse and
and jug meat together uh go from
cafeteria to med bay because i'm
watching you on admin
uh i just assumed that it was going to
be will or jug me
whoever died 100 yeah
likely had to be one of the killers
indicated by the fact that we're in a
four-way
meaning there's one killer or they'd
have advantage the game would be over
don't vote right now based on math we
have to make the killer
actually do something okay we have to or
we have to literally finish our test i'm
done i've been done with my time i'm
done with my tasks i've been known for
it
victoria you're very quiet i haven't
done my i think i have one more task to
do that
and i saw his son yeah no it's victoria
it's victoria
wait we can't vote this is we're jumping
to conclusions this is what they want us
to do don't vote on a four-way because
uh it's
okay let's listen i have i have one more
task to do
in the far right i don't know what the
idea is i'll do my last task and i think
we might win on tasks
okay tascarones let's try it
okay ready wait who has an emergency
buzzer left hassan and victoria
after after 40 seconds no matter what
hit the buzzer
okay okay let's go
we got this wow
this is wild
unless we have to fix something
what's the plan victoria what are you
gonna do
literally what are you gonna do i mean
you gotta sabotage
which i feel like corpse could be
helping out a bit more with that unless
he did that
you gotta split him up reactor
would be what i would do and then you
just kill
no but then the other two will know that
they were together
that doesn't necessarily work like that
it's it's a tough play but it can be
done i have done it what are you doing
in here
very confused
by the strats victoria very very unclear
on the plan
is teleporting around the map for anyone
else because it's scaring the hell out
of me yeah he is
he is for me as well i was gonna mention
that
he he he teleported when i saw you
uh but that's just that's probably just
uh
this is a ping problem it's a little
late anybody have any tasks left
no i haven't had tasks for a while it's
just ghosts that are not doing them i
think that's it it's got to be
god like i haven't had tasks in in like
four or five rounds almost uh victoria
is the only other person who
wait who was on the button i was i was
the one who did the other
reactor button hit the buzzer
okay so you were the one who did the
other reactor and the one who came in
late
i think it might be victoria because jug
meat hit the button yeah i
i think that's enough for me to i think
that's enough for me to slow us victoria
just to end this one but uh i mean
yeah let's roll it let's do it there's
no because there's no no one's doing it
like no one no one's doing their tests
it's a ghost
so we're just we're stuck we're just
going to keep repeating this
cycle over and over again i'm voting
they're right right they already have
advantage unless we both skip
victoria do you have any compelling
argument i
honestly do not i'm sorry clint compel
me victoria i don't know
very nervous compel me not saying
i'm like why are you listening victoria
100 i voted victoria
i said the word yeet i said yeet a bunch
of times
[Laughter]
do we win oh my god please
please please did a song swindle us
oh that would be something yes
the record needs to say it was corpse
it was not aoc
yeah so brutal to watch
yeah wait wait wait wait no corp sounded
so sad when i
when he saw him i was dead i was like
i'm so sorry oh my god
victoria how did you do that i was with
you ninety percent of that round right
at the end apparently if i wasn't so
confused about not being able to vote
then i would have gotten away with it
but i was just like
i i actually oh wait getting all the
bugs
it always happens to me it always
happens to me mm-hmm
dude you you actually swindled me
yeah you got marinated hard that was
tough to watch
i would have been like what happened
with the numbers
okay are you guys ready for this yes yes
we started the game at what 105k
yes yes and
we are now at 185.
oh
we got to restart by the way someone
else joined i think the lobby because
someone
leaked code right it was me it was me
um but i i also have to jump off me
check me i got bumped i'm out of here
so so much okay so uh
are we restarting in the lobby
everyone's still in i have to go because
my food is outside and i need to go eat
um but that is absolutely amazing
we could play one without thank you all
so much
thank you guys i don't want to keep
anyone here i don't want to force anyone
to stay here we can do something else
that's fine um i'm here in my own free
will and i'm enjoying it
good times
what's going to happen at 200 then when
we when we hit 200
what are you going to do then
[Music]
are you going to keep are you going to
keep playing with this aoc what are you
gonna do
i don't know how about how about you
tweet a smiley face
i could tweet a smiley face if we get
200k we'll see the smiley face
i don't know if this is just gonna turn
into like the h bomber guy stream where
i'm up like three minutes from now
no that's why no no that it is happening
that's why i'm trying to i i will help a
lot with that i will
i'll get the smiley face going it'll be
i'm i will reply
to count with a smiley face in return
look at us go let's do it i don't know
follow me back it's crazy smiley face
we're gonna we're gonna make you a
full-time streamer
yeah at 200k aoc becomes full-time
streamer
okay do you want to keep star wars
everyone else keep going
i am jumping out right now so thank you
guys so much everyone keep donating
that's absolutely amazing and have a
good night
all right that is me my food is here i
gotta go
eat and then i have some work to do
thank you everyone for watching
i hope the chat wasn't too bad i was not
reading it
i'll see you guys next time bye